where's your hand and wish I could
high-five you wait can you okay
wait do it again yay I love nugget
chicken nuggets are like a passion for
sure whenever I'm super drunk and I go
to McDonald's I get like 20 chicken
nuggets and I eat most of them a good
nugget has to have a good breading two
nugget ratio I'd be on the outside but
tender on the inside
this is 100% McDonald's I can just tell
by the shape Oh Julie it isn't burger
it's a little bland this is from Wendy's
how crunchy this is a sculpture of sort
oh well if that oh okay
interesting shape you can chip a tooth
on this wing meaty if you look it smells
like Popeyes so I'm into it
husky well nugget oh man why is it so
like soft this one well it doesn't
really taste very flavorful
maybe it's like like a 7-eleven they
says McDonald's I can tell okay
I know you can tell cuz it tastes like
rubber it's like too moist it's like too
moist like you're like how is it so
moist
that is a good nugget there's McDonald's
yeah this is Ronald definitely my man
Ronald shoutout
the chicken places know how to make
chicken nuggets better than the burger
places the 7/7 like really like the meat
tasted like okay 7-eleven was definitely
the worst nugget the worst one
it just it was shaped weirdly it looked
like play-doh that was just coming apart
I'm still McDonald's or Wendy's guy